[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend ihnen allen Norbert Lehmann
ist auch dabei für den Sport
schauen wir auf die Nachrichten Themen
von heute
Spuren eines Angriffs wieder traf es die
strategisch wichtige krim-brücke ein
Terrorakt sagt Moskau beklagt zwei Tote
und beschuldigt Kiel
bahnfrei im Sommer bis mindestens Ende
August haben Zugreisende keine Streiks
zu befürchten ab heute läuft im
Tarifkonflikt die geheime Schlichtung
und Wachwechsel in Wimbledon ein
packendes Finale 16 Jahre
Altersunterschied und diesmal beißt sich
der jüngere durch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zwei Themen bestimmen heute die
Kriegsberichterstattung zum einen das
getreideabkommen mit Russland damit
konnten im vergangenen Jahr trotz Krieg
33 Millionen Tonnen Getreide und andere
Lebensmittel aus der Ukraine exportiert
werden auch in die ärmsten Länder der
Welt doch jetzt weigert sich Moskau das
Abkommen zu verlängern zudem gab es in
der Nacht einen Angriff auf die
krim-brücke
diese Brücke verbindet die annektierte
Krim mit dem russischen Festland sie ist
für die Versorgung der Bevölkerung und
der russischen Truppen sehr wichtig ihre
Beschädigung jetzt entsprechend
bedeutsam für beide Seiten Claudia
Weiler berichtet
am Morgen untersuchen Sie die Schäden
die zwei Explosionen an der Brücke zur
Krim mitten in der Nacht verursacht
haben ein Mann und eine Frau sterben
ihre Tochter überlebt Russland spricht
von einem Terrorakt
die Ermittlungen identifizieren Personen
aus den ukrainischen sonderdiensten und
anderen bewaffneten Gruppen die an der
Durchführung dieses Verbrechens
beteiligt sind
schon im Oktober war die krimbrücke Ziel
eines Angriffs geht sie doch als
strategisch wichtiger Nachschubweg die
Verantwortung für den Angriff heute
weist die Ukraine zunächst zurück dann
gibt es Meldungen der ukrainische
Inlandsgeheimdienst bekenne sich zu dem
Angriff doch es ist das getreideabkommen
das dann im Laufe des Tages alle
Diskussionen überschattet in wenigen
Stunden läuft es aus und moskau will es
nicht verlängern weil Teile der
Vereinbarung nicht erfüllt worden sein
russische dünge und Lebensmittel nicht
von den Sanktionen ausgeklammert wurden
das Außenministerium stellt Bedingungen
nur bei Erhalt konkreter Ergebnisse und
keiner versprechen und Versicherungen
wird Russland bereit sein eine
Wiederherstellung des Deals zu prüfen
die UNO kritisiert den Ausstieg deutlich
fürchtet Folgen für Millionen Menschen
die jetzt schon von Hunger bedroht sind
die heutige Entscheidung wird Menschen
in Not einen schweren Schlag versetzen
zumindest hier im ukrainischen Ismael an
den Ufern der Donau geht der Export
weiter
200.000 Tonnen sind es jeden Monat über
den Umweg Rumänien geht es dann auf die
Weltmeere
wir haben den nie getraut und haben vom
ersten Tag des Krieges versucht eine
neue Logistik zu finden
über den Fluss exportieren sie deutlich
weniger als früher über die sehhäfen und
teurer ist es auch aber immerhin jede
Tonne die hier rausgeht ist unabhängig
vom getreideabkommen
für begeister mir unsere Moskau
Korrespondentin für Bewahrung stellt
sich Putin quer und will dieses Abkommen
nicht verlängern ja offiziell heißt es
aus Moskau ja das liege daran dass eben
die Erleichterung nicht gekommen sind
die versprochen wurden für den Export
von russischen Düngemitteln und
russischen akraprodukten aber ich denke
es gibt noch mindestens zwei andere
Faktoren die eine Rolle gespielt haben
erstens dieser Angriff heute auf die
krimbrücke mehrere russische Politiker
die spekulieren heute darüber dass
dieser Angriff nur möglich gewesen sei
durch den sicherheitskorridor der für
das ukrainische Getreide geschaffen
wurde und ob das stimmt oder nicht sei
mal dahingestellt klar ist aber dass das
ein riesiger Imageverlust für das
russische Regime war dieser Angriff auf
dieses Prestige Objekt und der zweite
Faktor den ich noch sehe ist moskau ist
Enttäuschung über Erdogans Auftritt in
Willi News der türkische Präsident hatte
das Getreide Abkommen ja mit vermittelt
und in Moskau hatte man sich ganz sicher
mehr Gegenwind von ihm versprochen auf
dem NATO-Gipfel als es um die
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
gegen genau diese türkische Präsident
erdogan ist aber optimistisch dass sein
Freund Putin wie er sagt doch noch
zustimmt
erdogan hat aber auch am Freitag schon
gesagt dass man sich einig geworden sei
über die Verlängerung des Getreide
Abkommens und ich sehe auch da zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder Erdogan schätzt
seinen Einfluss als Vermittler hier
größer ein als er tatsächlich ist oder
der türkische Präsident hat noch einen
Trumpf im Ärmel den wir noch nicht
kennen vielen Dank für diese
Informationen für
Ringen um den Getreide Deal welche
Folgen würde das Ende des Abkommens
haben Antworten auf die wichtigsten
Fragen finden Sie in unserer ZDF
heute-app etwa auch dazu was es für die
Preisentwicklung bedeuten würde und für
die globale Ernährungssicherheit
es sind die schlimmsten Verbrechen die
es gibt Völkermord Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit Kriegsverbrechen und es
sind die bei denen es am schwersten ist
die Täter zur Verantwortung zu ziehen
das versucht seit 25 Jahren der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof wie der
funktioniert und wo seine Grenzen liegen
erläutert Delia Thomas
am 17 Juli 1998 wurde in Rom die
Gründung des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs beschlossen
2002 nahm er seine Arbeit auf er hat
seinen Sitz in niederländischen Den Haag
und verfolgt Straftaten wie Völkermord
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit und
Kriegsverbrechen
vor dem Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
werden keine Staaten angeklagt sondern
Einzelpersonen und zwar dann wenn das in
ihrem Staaten nicht geschieht
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof ist
unabhängig er wird auf Initiative des
eigenen Anklägers desto ein
Sicherheitsrates oder eines
Vertragsstaates aktiv
124 Staaten unterstützen die Arbeit des
Internationalen Gerichtshofs allerdings
fehlen wichtige Staaten wie die USA
China und Russland in Hinblick auf den
Ukraine Krieg bedeutet dies der vom
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof gegen
Putin erlassene Haftbefehl hat den
Russland erstmal keine Wirkung
ein Vierteljahrhundert Strafgerichtshof
zu diesem Jubiläum gibt es heute bei der
UNO in New York einen Festakt dort wird
auch diskutiert ob und viruslands
Präsident Putin doch irgendwann durch
den Haag zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden
kann für die Bundesregierung ist
Außenministerin baerbock vor Ort schon
im Vorfeld hatte sie erneut dafür
geworben das Völkerrecht so anzupassen
dass Angriffskriege in Zukunft leichter
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden können
fragen wir Andreas kühners in New York
was will die Außenministerin erreichen
also was Deutschland hier heute beginnt
ist der Versuch Präsidenten Staatschefs
Regierungschefs nicht mehr nur für
einzelne ganz konkrete Kriegsverbrechen
vor den internationalen
strafgerichtshofstellen zu können
sondern schon für den Befehl des
Angriffs auf ein anderes Land für das
Verbrechen der Aggressionen da sind die
rechtlichen Hürden bisher so hoch dass
sich die Oberbefehlshaber die
Staatslenker dieser Welt im Prinzip
sicher fühlen können und das will
Werbung zusammen mit einer ganzen Gruppe
von Staaten jetzt ändern will diese
Hürden senken aber sie wird sich dafür
wenn sie es ernst meint auch anlegen
müssen mit befreundeten Staaten die den
Strafgerichtshof ja zum Teil gar nicht
anerkannt haben mit der Ukraine z.B und
vor allem mit den USA und daran sieht
man das wird ein sehr langer sehr
mühsamer Weg von dem am Ende keiner weiß
ob er überhaupt zum Ziel führen wird und
dass ihr heute kann allenfalls an
allererster Schritt sein
live aus New York Andreas Künast vielen
Dank
nach Deutschland wenn in Tarif
Konflikten nichts mehr geht müssen die
schlicht daran um die rettende Formel
auszuloten die beide Seiten gerade noch
erträglich finden die beiden Seiten das
sind diesmal die Bahn und die
Gewerkschaft EVG die schon seit Monaten
über Löhne und Laufzeiten streiten
scheitern die schlichte gibt es wohl
Streik Hans-jürgen Kiel berichtet
zweimal hat die EVG den Schienenverkehr
bundesweit lahmgelegt seit Februar ringt
sie mit der db-umhöre Gehälter doch die
Verhandlungen sind festgefahren sie
sollen jetzt einen Kompromiss finden
Heide Pfarr und Thomas de Maizière die
arbeitsrechtlerin unter frühere
Bundesinnenminister beginnen an
unbekanntem Ort ein
Schlichtungsverfahren ich denke
gestreikt ist nun genug es reicht mehr
möchte ich nicht ich hoffe sehr auf eine
Einigung denn bei einem weiteren Streik
sind die falschen betroffen mit
privatbahnbetreibern hat sich die EVG
schon geeinigt bei der DB könnte die
Schlichtung die Chancen jetzt zumindest
erhöhen sie Schlichtung ist ein
erfolgreiches Instrument wir haben dazu
20 Branchen beobachtet mit fast 50
Schlichtungen seit 2000 und da stellt
man fest dass zwei von drei
Schlichtungen erfolgreich sind auch bei
der Bahn trifft das so doch in
Kernpunkten liegen die Tarifparteien
hier noch weitauseinander 650 € mehr
Gehalt fordert die EVG bei einer
Laufzeit von 12 Monaten letztes Angebot
der Bahn am Verhandlungstisch waren
100 Euro bei 27 Monaten Vertragsdauer
dazu eine Einmalzahlung Ende nächster
Woche soll ein Schlichtungsergebnis
vorliegen danach werden unsere
Mitglieder entscheiden in der
Urabstimmung ob sie weitere
Streikmaßnahmen in Betracht ziehen oder
das Angebot annehmen und das ganze wird
bis Ende August dauern und bis dahin
muss auch kein Fahrgast in Deutschland
mit weiteren streitmaßnahmen rechnen
sollten drei Viertel der
Gewerkschaftsmitglieder der
schlichteangebot jedoch ablehnen droht
unbefristeter Bahnstreik ab September
in Berlin ist zum zweiten Mal ein
klimaaktivist der sogenannten letzten
Generation zu einer Haftstrafe ohne
Bewährung verurteilt worden wegen drei
Straßenblockaden und weil er im
Bundestag einen Feueralarm ausgelöst
hatte muss der 31-Jährige für vier
Monate ins Gefängnis eine
Bewährungsstrafe lehnte das Amtsgericht
Tiergarten ab der Aktivist sei
Wiederholungstäter und habe im Prozess
auch keinen Sinneswandel erkennen lassen
ein großer Gipfel große Weltpolitik
heute auf der Brüsseler Bühne mehr als
50 Staats- und Regierungschefs treffen
sich zum eu-lateinamerika Gipfel auch da
geht es um den ukrainekrieg einige
Beteiligte Länder wie zum Beispiel
Venezuela gelten als Verbündete
Russlands
aber es geht auch um das geplante
Freihandelsabkommen Mercosur mit den
vier lateinamerikanischen Staaten
Brasilien Argentinien Paraguay Uruguay
und der Europäischen Union mit zusammen
720 Millionen Menschen und es hakt
Europa fordert höhere Umweltauflagen
sehr zum Ärger Brasiliens ultra
Ricardo Bartolo baut bio-café in
Brasilien an die machen die strengen
eu-umweltauflagen sorgen nur wenn er sie
einhält darf er den Kaffee dahin
exportiert bereits seine eigene
Regierung verlangt von ihm dass er 20
Prozent seines Grundstückes als
Schutzgebiet mit ursprünglicher
Vegetation erhält
ich denke wir leisten schon einen sehr
großen Beitrag erklärt Bartolo ich
glaube europa sollte unsere Leistungen
im Umweltschutz anerkennen
freundliche Empfang für den
brasilianischen Präsidenten in Brüssel
der fühlt sich aber durch Europas
Umweltauflagen bevormundet denn Lula
sieht sich selbst als Beschützer des
Regenwaldes
wir haben die Abholzung des Regenwaldes
schon um 80% reduziert und wir werden
sie auf 0 bis 2030 zurückfahren
die EU sucht die Nähe zu Lateinamerika
auch um den immer stärker werdenden
Einfluss von Ländern wie China
zurückzudringen diese Annäherung gelingt
nur als gleichberechtigte Partner ich
bin
sehr dafür dass wir diese Abkommen
abschließen und ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir das in einer Weise machen wo dann
auf allen Seiten alle sagen das ist
jetzt gut gelungen und das ist nicht
etwas das mit vormacht zu tun hat mit
Übermacht sondern das auf Augenhöhe
stattfindet das Freihandelsabkommen ist
noch
nicht Tücher denn Brasilien und
Argentinien sind arkanationen und würden
zum Beispiel dem Agrarland Frankreich
Konkurrenz machen mit zollfreien
Produkten das sorgt für Streit
zum Auftakt der Sitzung harmonische Töne
für eine Beziehung die sich noch
entwickeln muss
eine andere Vereinbarung hat die EU
gestern mit Tunesien getroffen fast eine
Milliarde Euro zahlt Brüssel damit
Tunesien künftig Migranten von einer
Überfahrt über das Mittelmeer abhält
doch es gibt auch deutliche Kritik an
dem Abkommen vor allem wegen des Umgangs
der tunesischen Behörden mit
Flüchtlingen hunderte waren letzte Woche
ohne Hilfe und ohne Trinkwasser in der
Wüste ausgesetzt worden einige konnten
von libyschen Grenzbeamten und
Hilfsorganisationen gerettet werden von
anderen fehlt jede Spur
in vielen Regionen rund ums Mittelmeer
ist es glühend heiß die dritte
Hitzewelle innerhalb eines Monats lässt
in Spanien die Temperaturen vielerorts
auf mehr als 40 Grad steigen Italien hat
deshalb die Warnungen verstärkt die
Menschen sollen möglichst nur morgens
oder abends ins Freie gehen in
Griechenland sind mehrere Waldbrände
ausgebrochen
auch im Südwesten der USA leiden die
Menschen unter extremer Hitze und das
schon seit Wochen ursache ist ein
stabiles Hochdruckgebiet dass die heiße
Luft wie einen Deckel an Ort und Stelle
hält betroffen sind weite Teile des
Landes in Texas etwa waren es gestern
gut 41 Grad Celsius in Kalifornien knapp
43 und in Arizona bis zu 49 Grad über
die Glut Hitze berichtet Elmar Tee
Wissen
Monique Hebert und andere Freiwillige
wollen helfen in der Hitze bringen
Kühlung für die Obdachlosen Aufmunterung
für ermattete Hitzeschutz für
Hundepfoten seit 18 Tagen liegen die
Temperaturen in Phoenix Arizona um und
über 40 Grad Celsius nur so erträglich
und doch gefährlich auch weil der Boden
und die Spielgeräte so heiß sind
bei 60 bis 80 Grad entstehenden Sekunden
Brandwunden an den Kinderhänden am
schlimmsten ist es für die die im Freien
leben sie Tränken Tücher in Wasser
werden im kühlnägel einer rollenden
Klinik von Ärzten beraten drinnen sitzt
Kevin Händler Schott in seinen zwölf
Jahren auf der Straße hat der so eine
Hitze noch nicht erlebt
ich bin auf dem heißen Asphalt
eingeschlafen und hatte dann
Verbrennungen dritten Grades an meiner
linken Seite da merkst du was los ist
extrem Wetter durch Klimawandel nach
heftigen Regenfällen im Nordosten
sterben Menschen in den Überschwemmungen
fünf allein hier in Pennsylvania am
Sonntag einen 9 Monate alter Junge und
ein zweijähriges Mädchen werden noch
vermisst
wir suchen weiter nach den zwei Kindern
wir geben nicht auf trotz des Wetters
es ist ein Sommer der extreme
gleichzeitig brennen in Kalifornien
Wälder Menschen sollen ihre Häuser
verlassen und kein Ende in Sicht neue
hitzewarnungen für die nächsten Tage
betreffen 100 Millionen Amerikaner
in Paris sehr viel angenehmer bei 25°c
drin holte über die 200 Meter gold
Glauben Irmgard Ben Susen verteidigt
ihren WM-Titel und ist auf 200 Metern
nicht zu schlagen damit gerechnet
genau
26,82 Sekunden waren es die 32-Jährige
Ben Susan konnte am Donnerstag beim 100
Meter Sprints keine Medaille holen ist
da nur sechste geworden hier auf den 200
Metern ist sie umso schneller holt sich
den Sieg wortwörtlich auf den letzten
Metern wenn Susan bleibt Weltmeisterin
beste Voraussetzungen für die
Paralympics im kommenden Jahr auch
wieder hier in Paris
und die Nummer eins im Tennis bleibt
Carlos nach seinem furiosen final
gestern Abend in Wimbledon das
20-jährige Ausnahme Talent schlägt den
36-Jährigen Superstar Hannover jokovic
ja ein Generationswechsel an der Spitze
hat begonnen
Carlos alcaras dritt jüngster Wimbledon
Champion aller Zeiten die Wachablösung
nach einem epischen fünf satz-finale
gegen sein Idol
als ich geboren wurde warst du schon
längst dabei Turniere zu gewinnen du
warst meine Inspiration
alcaras besiegte Djokovic dort wo dieser
unschlagbar schien in mentaler Stärke
Fitness und der Gabe sich schnell
anpassen zu können war der 20-Jährige
nur außen besser als sein 16 Jahre
älterer Gegner
ich dachte ich bekomme auch Sand und
Hartplatz Probleme mit dir aber nicht
auf Rasen das scheint nur anders zu sein
Djokovic war angetreten seinen achten
Titel zu gewinnen nach vier Stunden und
42 Minuten hatte humbledonkaras als
König eine neue Ära hat begonnen
in einer Woche WM Auftakt gegen Marokko
das DFB-Team kann wohl doch mit Lena
Oberdorf Plan die Oberschenkel Verletzte
mittelspielerin war gestern wieder beim
Training dabei ja heute ein Feiertag für
die deutschen Frauen Sightseeing war
angesagt inklusive eines
spektakulärenwatching in der Bucht
ja und wir freuen uns auf hoffentlich
spektakuläre Siege der deutschen Frauen
bei dieser WM Absolution war aber auch
schon schön vielen Dank Norbert die
große Hitze bleibt uns vorerst
weitgehend erspart mir zum Wetter gleich
von Katja horneffer das heute journal um
Viertel mit Christian Sievers danke für
Ihr Interesse einen schönen Abend ihnen
noch und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend schon heute kletterten die
Temperaturen in Algerien bis 46 Grad
rund um das Mittelmeer liegen die
Nachttemperaturen häufig bei 30 bis 25
Grad deutlich frischer wird die Nacht
bei uns uns erwarten nämlich meistwerte
zwischen 12 und 8 Grad etwas weniger
frisches im Norden im Osten und im Süden
Deutschlands und am mildesten bleibt die
Nacht östlich von München mit 17 Grad
dort wie auch an der Ostsee ziehen noch
letzte Regenschauer und auch kurze
Gewitter ab sonst ist es häufig klar und
morgen beginnt der Tag erstmal mit viel
Sonne und den letzten Regenschauern hier
in der Ostsee am Nachmittag gibt's dann
aber wieder mehr Regenschauer von der
Nordsee her und zum späten Nachmittag
und Abend entwickeln sich dann im
Schwarzwald am Bodensee und auch im
Allgäu zum Teil auch mal kräftigere
Gewitter unter den Schauer Wolken in
Norddeutschland liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 20 bis 24 Grad
sonst steigen Sie auf 25 bis 30 Grad und
wechselhaft geht's dann auch in den
nächsten Tagen weiter bei Temperaturen
von 18 bis 30 Grad die meisten Zeit
trocken ist es dagegen im Südwesten
guten Abend